salut aujourd'hui vous l'avez compris on
va parler des pervers narcissique et de
personnes toxiques et de relation
toxique mais avant de rentrer dans le
vif du sujet il plus qu'essentiel de
parler également de qu'est ce qu'on
appelle lé pervers narcissique
aujourd'hui en psychiatrie cette notion
case de pervers narcissique n'a pas
d'existence de la muséographie ci qui a
trick c'est à dire l'endroit où on
référence toutes les maladies donc ce
n'est pas reconnu comme quelque chose
qui existe de la part des psychiatres
qui émettent au contraire beaucoup de
réserve l'expression pervers narcissique
a été proposée en 1986 par un psychiatre
justement paul claude racamier cette
notion sera ensuite reprise est utilisé
par des psychiatres que marie france
hirigoyen gualberto et guay qui vont
décrire la souffrance des victimes qui
fréquentent ce type de personnalité
pourtant l'expression elle même pervers
narcissique et complètement discutable
ne serait ce que par le sens pervers
narcissique puisque tout pervers a déjà
un problème de narcissisme extrême du
coup ça fait un petit peu redondant
c'est un peu plus au nas ce qui fait que
pervers narcissique ça devient une
espèce de diagnostic est très réducteur
en fait très schématique ça peut
empêcher de voir d'autres problèmes
d'autres troubles que possède la
personne tels que l'appareil yahoo des
états limitent ou simplement dans le
cadre donc d'une relation entre deux
personnes que ce soit de la famille un
couple et c'est
plus simplement une relation malade qui
demanderaient justement peut-être une
analyse beaucoup plus subtil de la part
d'un professionnel même si 4 par exemple
cette introduction un petit peu longue
sur la controverse de l'utilisation de
ce mot était importante pour la suite de
cette vidéo je vais utiliser le terme
pervers narcissique ou le raccourci pn
tout le long de la vidéo mais soyons
bien clair il s'agit pas d'un diagnostic
puisqu'on le sait ça n'existe pas en
psychiatrie en tant que tel ça n'a pas
tellement plus de valeur que de dire les
personnes sympas où les personnes pas
sympa dans le cadre de cette vidéo le
terme pervers narcissique ou pn veut
dire pour moi et pour le cadre de cette
vidéo donc non pas un diagnostic mais
une typologie de personnes ayant un mois
plus tôt le lacunaire plutôt narcissique
avec un mécanisme de fonctionnement qui
consiste à dévaloriser l'autre pour
nourrir son côté narcissique
voilà ce que ça voudra dire pour cette
vidéo c'est de ce genre de personne
toxiques dont je parle ici on y
reviendra d'ailleurs dans la vidéo de
comment ça se fait qu'on voit des
pervers narcissique partout c'est l'une
des parties de cette vidéo on y
reviendra est-ce qu'il faut aider ce
genre de personne si oui comment on y
reviendra également merci beaucoup de
nous intéresser à cette vidéo qui
j'espère sera utile aux personnes qui le
regarderont et n'oubliez pas d'une
manière générale des maîtres les plus
grosses réserves quant à l'utilisation
est ce que veut dire le terme pervers
narcissique ou pn
salut aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler
d'un sujet que je pensais avoir déjà
traité sur la chaîne depuis 2016 et
aurait été non c'est celui des pervers
narcissique alors on dit pervers
narcissique on pourrait dire personnes
atteintes de troubles de la personnalité
sociopathe ou plus généralement les
personnes toxiques mais toxiques
réellement pourquoi parce qu'elles sont
atteintes d'une ou deux pathologies tout
d'abord une pathologie narcissique ce
sont des personnes qui se trouvent
grandiose qui se trouve importante elle
même est une pathologie perverse
c'est-à-dire sont des personnes qui sont
sadi qui vont prendre du plaisir dans le
fait de faire du mal aux autres pourquoi
faire une vidéo sur le sujet parce que
je crois que plus que jamais c'est
important d'en parler c'est important
pour les personnes qui en sont victimes
et qu'ils ne s'en rendent pas encore
compte précisément et ça on va y revenir
pour les personnes qui ont nom était
victime et c'est important aussi de dire
bah oui ces personnalités là elle existe
statistiquement il ya beaucoup plus
d'hommes que de femmes qui sont
manipulateur pervers ça veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas de femmes qui existe dans
ce domaine là mais c'est souvent les
hommes et c'est pourquoi je veux
conjuguer tout cette vidéo au masculin
mais on pourrait très bien jean rey au
féminin de même manière je le fais par
simplicité enfin par simplicité et puis
encore une fois parce que
statistiquement c'est plus souvent le
cas des hommes de la même manière j'ai
souvent parlé de coupe parce que pour
qui un pervers narcissique faut qu'il y
ait une victime en face pour qu'ils
puissent devrais je donc je parle du
couple pervers narcissique victimes pas
forcément du couple amoureux c'est ça
peut être aussi familial ça peut être
une mère avec son enfant ça peut être un
patron avec son employée ça peut se
retrouver dans plein de schémas et puis
c'est important d'en parler aussi si
vous dans votre entourage vous pensez
que quelqu'un est victime d'un
manipulateur pervers la vidéo avait à se
découper sur la difficulté de repérer un
pervers narcissique sur les différences
qui entre un pervers narcissique et
d'autres comportements de type de
personnalité sur la stratégie du pervers
narcissique également et on va centrer
évidemment sur la victime sur les effets
que ça sur la victime sur la grande
question est ce qu'il faut aider ou pas
un pervers narcissique sur les solutions
pour s'en sortir et on terminera en
parlant de ce qui va se passer également
quand le pervers narcissique n'aura plus
d'emprise sur la victime qu'est ce qui
va lui faire subir en rebond et ça c'est
très important également loïc générique
[Musique]
donc un pervers narcissique on appelle
aussi parfois un pn alors on pense qu'il
y en a partout que c'est le mal de la
génération c'est pas aussi fréquents
parce qu'on pense bien souvent on accole
des tickets pervers narcissique à des
personnes qui n'en sont pas vraiment
mais c'est quand même 3 % de la
population en moyenne trois personnes
sur cent c'est quand même pas rien
sachant qu'en plus statistiquement
interne artistique va faire au moins
trois vraies victimes au cours de sa vie
donc ça démultiplie un petit peu suivre
ce sont des personnes qui ont conscience
qu'ils font du mal mais qui ne ressemble
pas vraiment ses terres qu ils
ressentent qu'ils font du mal mais pour
eux c'est pas très clean air que cette
émotion là en fait c'est pas très clair
que le mal ce soit du mal ils vont au
contraire s'amuser et trouver une forme
de jouissance dans la souffrance de la
victime ou des victimes une grande
interrogation c'est pourquoi ils font ça
à part le plaisir la jouissance qui
peuvent retirer à faire du mal à
quelqu'un il ya une explication qui est
en psychologie hassan mise c'est le fait
que ces personnes là sont au bord de la
folie et tout ce système qu'elle met en
place avec les victimes elles le font
pour pas des compensées elles mêmes la
décompensation on appelle ça aussi
l'effondrement psychologique ça
correspond à la phase de rupture
psychologique d'une personne alors
l'idée même si elle n'est pas consciente
c'est de rendre l'autre fou à sa propre
place dire que en victimisant une
personne mais en allant au bout du
processus by this voilà ça c'est
quelqu'un de fou moi je suis pas fou
hein et puis en plus tout ça c'est de ta
faute à toi du coup c'est jamais de ma
faute à moi c'est à peu près les bases
du fondement du comportement d'un
pervers narcissique ils sont très
difficiles à repérer en apparence en
premier lieu alors on pourra aussi les
appelait les prédateurs moreau en
général ils ont une vie sociale très
épanouie et c'est des personnes qui
passent très bien socialement qui ont
même tendance à briller à capter
l'attention ils ont souvent un charisme
alors ce pas forcément physiques c'est
la manière d'être ils savent être en
fait en société ils sont socialement
très adapté ils sont très intelligents
et ils sont très stratèges ils ont
souvent un sens de l'élocution donc on
les écoute assez facilement et c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs que tout commence
avec les pervers narcissique c'est parce
que d'une part tout le monde les aime
donc personne va remettre en question ce
qu'ils vont dire et d'autre part ils
peuvent capter une victime plus
facilement parce qu'ils sont un petit
peu facilement pourtant dans les
premiers points de repères qu'on
pourrait avoir c'est que ce sont des
personnes un peu au discours
monolithique terre d'un seul bloc qui
connaissent qu'une seule chose et encore
ce serait modeuses monolithique creux
parce qu'il n'y a pas grand chose à
l'intérieur donc ils sont compétents
d'armes de savoir sur un point précis
alors ce savoir là ils vont souvent
l'étaler ils vont souvent répété la même
chose
au cours des soirées entre amis dès
qu'il rencontre quelqu'un ils ont ils
ont un schéma comme ça de séduction où
il brille mais toujours avec la même
chose en fait au final ils ont l'air
plus intelligent que ce qu'ils ne sont
ce qui veut dire que pour eux les autres
se sont pas vraiment des autres ce sont
des fans bâlois à l'ego mais ce sont
presque des objets qui vont pouvoir
s'amuser en fait à détruire cccd jouer à
détruire cette empathie la humaine à
l'existant pas tellement ou tu me serres
où tu me sert à ne pas des compensées
donc je vais te détruire ou tu dois
m'adresser à adorent mois où il n'existe
pas et même si c'est prédateurs moreau
arrive à détruire moralement leurs
victimes c'est pas ce n'est pas
satisfaisant pour à aucun moment il ya
une issue pour que le pervers
narcissique ce sens d'où bien et se
sentent comblés puisque le problème en
réalité ce n'est pas les autres c'est
lui le problème donc peu importe qui
fait aux autres ça lui permet
effectivement de compenser ou d'éviter
de les compenser ça lui permet pas
d'aller mieux et ce sont des personnes
qui du coup vont aussi au delà des
victimes bannir ni plus ni moins les
personnes qui ne pensent pas comme eux
qui ne sont pas dans leur courant de
pensée ou qui ne trouvent pas grâce à
leurs yeux c'est à dire que par exemple
un pervers narcissique s'il a un
problème
avec quelqu'un qui n'aime pas plutôt que
de l'éviter il ira plus facilement voir
quelqu'un qui les connaît tous les deux
en commun pour lui dire mais lui tu
devrais jamais lui parler et c'est alors
que l'autre n'a rien demandé et que la
relation était pas parasitaire il va
essayer de punir en réalité toutes les
personnes qui ne le trouvent pas assez
brillant qui ne nourrissent pas en fait
son narcissisme ou pire qui ont osé les
contredire et là quand je vous prends
l'exemple d'aller voir une tierce
personne etc c'est parce que ce sont pas
des bourrins de la manipulation ils sont
stratèges ils sont quand même
intelligent dans la stratégie donc
bernard narcissique font preuve d'une
manipulation qui est très subtil et qui
est dur à déceler c'est ça qui les rend
si dur a repéré parce qu'il ya quelque
chose de très progressif et il ya
quelque chose mais ça on y reviendra
tout à l'heure avec les victimes de
l'ordre de l'isolément qui fait qu'on a
énormément de mal à se rendre compte
franchement au premier coup de dire
telle personne c'est un pervers
narcissique ou c'est une perverse
narcissique pire que ça c'est que dans
cette manipulation
subtil le pervers narcissique va va
remplir les manques des personnes qui va
choisir comme victime ou comme
potentielle victime dans le futur il va
apporter du bien à ce moment-là il a
apporté des choses dans la vie de
l'autre en remplissant les manques et
les vides et enfin dans la difficulté de
les repérer c'est qu'encore une fois
qu'ils se dévoilent progressivement en
huit lots jamais à l'extérieur même un
pervers narcissique qui est en pleine
action pas très envie d'utiliser cette
formulation mais je la trouve clair
cette action là elle sera pas vraiment
perçu par les autres parce que c'est
fait subtilement et quand c'est fait
moins subtilement s'est fait à huis clos
sans que personne ne puisse assister à
ça en public
le pervers narcissique et toujours
merveilleux et d'ailleurs en général on
a rien à redire c'est à dire que quand
quelqu'un se fait détectés par bernard
sik on se dit au contraire 91,8 c'est
pas possible parce qu'il est nickel
partout et bien ça c'est l'apanage des
pervers narcissique de coché toutes les
cases c'est presque bizarre d'être aussi
bien au final parce que nous on a tous
nos défauts j'ai plein de défauts vous
en avez aussi et c'est ce qui fait de
nous des êtres humains le fait que comme
par hasard ce soit des personnes où tout
est nickel et ya rien à redire ça
renforce en fait le l'impossibilité de
les détecter alors qu'en réalité ça
pourrait presque être un indice il
presque parce qu'on ne connaît jamais
une personne à 100% il ya des personnes
qui peuvent pas être très bien et qui
sont très bien encore alors pourquoi ce
mot pervers narcissique est tellement à
la mode pour qu'on l'a entendu par tous
ces dernières années c'est parce qu'il a
tendance à être confondu avec avec
quelqu'un qui est manipulateur ou
quelqu'un qui est méchant simplement
même quelqu'un étaient sadiques par
exemple c'est pas forcément un pervers
narcissique qui cumule bien deux
pathologies en même temps et puis et
puis il ya les actes qui sont qui sent
très visible en fait le schéma du
pervers narcissique j'insiste vraiment
dessus il est subtile il est très
pervers justement parce que il est caché
ici mise dans les vies dans l'esprit
d'une personne qui va détruire
complètement donc les conflits et les
clashs habituel où j'entends parfois lui
doit être pervers narcissique et c'est à
bas n'ont pas tellement parce que c'est
pas subtil et c'est plus quelqu'un qu'on
pourrait affubler d'un nom pas très
sympa pour ce qu'il vient de faire
mais ça veut pas forcément dire qu'il
est pervers narcissique donc le pervers
narcissique
des fois je dirais le pn vous formalisez
pas ça se dit aussi pour qu'il existe il
faut forcément une proie c'est un petit
peu comme le triangle de cartman donc
jeu dont je parle dans l'anti de la
manipulation c'est à dire que il ya les
trois halls 1 victime draw et sauveur et
bien puisque le pervers narcissique
c'est le bourreau en puissance pour
pouvoir s'épanouir il a forcément besoin
de créer une victime comment il va la
clé il va commencer par choisir une
proie et surtout le premier temps est
toujours le même c'est une séduction
alors pas forcément encore une fois une
séduction hausse d'un point de vue
amoureux mais c'est une séduction on
trouve la personne géniale et cette
personne a fait tout pour elle génial on
va la trouver extrêmement brillante
c'est quelqu'un qui va se rendre
indispensable qui va nous faire sentir
important ça c'est ça c'est aussi
essentiel c'est que la personne se sent
importante la victime pas parce qu'elle
est importante parce qu'elle se dit
qu'elle a de la chance que cette
personne si brillante s'intéresse à elle
c'est le premier mécanisme qu'on
retrouve dans tous les stratagèmes dans
toutes les stratégies des pervers
narcissique ça commence toujours comme
ça et c'est ce qui va lui permettre à
près de la paralyser littéralement la
paralyser on part souvent d'une forme
d'hypnose dents chez le pervers
narcissique alors c'est pas de l'hypnose
au sens hypnothérapie médical du terme
mais cette fascination elle est
tellement forte que ça fait presque un
état modifié de conscience où on ne
pense que par cette personne on ne
ressent que par son père der narcissique
par son bureau où il ya que cette
personne là qui compte parce qu'au fur
et à mesure il va lui montrer à quel
point il est la seule personne
importante de sa vie c'est ce qu'on
appelle la création d'une emprise une
fois que l'emprise est créé le pen passe
à la troisième phase l'isoler
socialement isolées sa victime
socialement alors c'est pas de la
jalousie que même si ça peut y
ressembler c'est surtout que c'est plus
simple de détruire une personne si elle
n'est pas conseillé en fait s'il ya
personne pour s'en rendre compte et pour
lui dire attends tu devrais faire
attention c'est pas normal qu'on comme
comportement ce genre de choses donc il
ya ça il ya certes sûrement une part
c'est impossible de le quantifier du
narcissisme qui fait qu' il ou elle veut
être la seule personne qui existe et qui
est admiré mais quoi qu'il arrive c'est
surtout pour détruire plus facilement là
psychologique cette personne il ya deux
manière d'isoler socialement isolées ça
veut pas forcément dire mettre la
personne tout seul dans une pièce sans
année ça c'est l'une des deux manières
la première manière c'est d'isoler au
sens littéral c'est à dire de dire
arrête tes amis je veux plus les voir
parce qu'ils sont comme ci comme ça tu
te rends pas compte ils sont comme ça en
plus ils disent du mal de toi là tous
les moyens sont bons pour isoler la
personne souvent en bloquant des
relations ou en amenant la personne à ne
plus vouloir elle aussi ses relations
par exemple en faisant preuve de
mensonges tu te rends pas compte mais
mes machin quand même il est super g de
toi il dit du mal de toi une critique et
c'est ce qui va isoler complètement la
personne donc alors plus de contacts
donc plus de conseils possibles la
deuxième manière qui est pas
antinomiques un des deux les deux
peuvent être fait en même temps c'est au
contraire de séduire les autres de
séduire les autres que tout le monde ne
trouve le gentil brillant attentionné et
caetera et caetera intelligent nickel en
tous points pour ensuite se les mettre
dans la poche et ensuite du coup créer
des conflits il peut ces personnes qui
l'a mis dans sa poche leur faire penser
du mal de la victime plutôt que de faire
à la victime pensait du mal des autres
dans tous les cas c'est un phénomène de
conflit vient ensuite la pierre des
phases la plus longue la quatrième phase
où le pm a disqualifié la personne fall
a désinformées fait la critique et vale
a abaissé à la détruire en permanence
son but est extrêmement simple la
rendent le plus minable possible mais
pas en lui démontrant qu'elle est
minable en lui faisant sentir qu'à les
minables en lui faisant comprendre elle
même qu'elle est minable dire que la
personne est persuadé que tout ce qui
est dit est vrai et c'est là où le mot
pervers prend son sens c'est la personne
qui va comprendre au final qu'elle ne
vaut rien qu'elle est minable qu'elle
n'est pas qu'elle ait jamais assez bien
qu'elle ne fait jamais assez la bonne
chose qu'elle n'est pas capable de toute
manière puisque c'est des mots qui m'ont
est utilisé par le pervers narcissique
et qui vont s'inscrire dans son propre
schéma de pensée vis-à-vis d'elle-même
alors après ça peut aller très loin sur
la manipulation jusqu'à l'agression
complète parce que cette agression
physique ou pire d'être justifiée par
des phrases tu vois ce que tu m'oblige à
faire tout ça c'est bien à cause de toi
toute manière à part moi qui va être
proche de toi dans la vie et ses acteurs
et si la personne se rebelle il ya la
fat supplémentaire qui leur la date où
les sommets c'est que pervers
narcissique va se faire passer pour la
victime auprès de la victime et c'est là
où il va y avoir une violence de
culpabilité pour pour ramasser toute la
culpabilité de la victime qu'elle avait
déjà un peu envers elle même parce
qu'elles n'arrivent pas à se situer
puisqu'elle est détruit
psychologiquement on va lui dire mais
tout ça c'est à cause de toi mais tu te
rends compte dans quel état chine
maintenant tu as vu ce que tu me fais
faire ce que tu etc mais je sacrifie
tout pour toi et c'est donc la victime
va se sentir coupable alors qu'elle
essayait juste de se rebeller de quelque
chose qui était logique on va s'arrêter
un petit peu sur cette notion là des
victimes la victime ça peut être
n'importe quel humain qui entoure le
pervers narcissique il n'y a pas de
catégorie spéciale ça peut être je vous
le disais tout à l'heure un collègue un
membre de la famille un conjoint ou une
conjointe etc le pervers narcissique
peut avoir plusieurs victimes mais ce
sera jamais au même degré le pervers
narcissique a toujours une victime de
prédilection et c'est là qu'il faut que
vous compreniez quelque chose dont je
pense on parle pas assez qu'on parle des
pervers narcissique c'est que pervers
narcissique va devenir lui aussi
dépendant de sa victime c'est pour ça
qu'il a principalement une victime de
victimes de prédilection maximum parce
que lui il va se nourrir un petit peu
comme comme un vampire qui se nourrirait
du centre quelqu'un il va il à se
nourrir toujours à la même source tout
aura été mis en place dont il a besoin
de pouvoir torturé psychologiquement
cette personne il a besoin de sentir son
emprise quelque part pour lui se
rassurer et pour éviter de tomber dans
sa propre défense parce que oui il doit
nourrir le côté pervers mais il doit
aussi détruire pour pouvoir jouir de
cette souffrance-là pour que cette
souffrance lui donne du plaisir
principalement le pervers narcissique va
donc dénigrer et s'attaquer au corps que
ce soit psychologiquement ou
physiquement à l'image que ce soit
psychologiquement ou physiquement et aux
compétences de sa victime en la
rabaissant toujours sur son niveau de
compétences quel que soit le domaine la
victime ne fera jamais ces biens ne
pense jamais à ces biens ne réfléchis
pas comme il faut les effets sur la
victime le premier effet qui est
terrible c'est que la victime se demande
si c'est elle ou lui qui n'est pas
normal les phrases qu'on entend souvent
des personnes qui ont été victimes de
par amar 6,6 et je me demandais si c'est
si je devenais fou si je devenais folle
ou si c'était lui ou elle qui était
folle je savais plus trop ça c'est
typiquement un principe de confusion on
retrouve justement aussi dans les états
hypnotique cette confusion allez allez
terrible à vivre parce que la personne
et est même plus capable de se dire la
situation n'est pas normale elle sait
plus si c'est pas elle même qu'à un
problème et si tout cette situation ce
n'est pas à cause d'elle évidemment dans
les effets sur la victime il ya la perte
de confiance en soi mais il ya également
aussi le stress permanent permanent
alors avec toutes les conséquences
physiques aussi que ça peut avoir
la perte de poids ou à la verse la prise
de poids tout ce qui est néfaste
vis-à-vis du stress cette personne ne
l'a vu le vivre à plein pot h 24 le
stress va engendrer par exemple le
manque de sommeil qui va engendrer la
mauvaise capacité de mémorisation de ses
journées et ses accès donc ça on dirait
des personnes qui sont pas attentifs
donc être prise qu'en plus de se prendre
des skates de leur entourage qui dit
mettez couteau rien tu fais pas
attention peut être tout ça c'est les
désagréments liés au stress permanent
qui devient presque comme un stress
chronique qui est générée par le pervers
narcissique et puis faut pas le négliger
c'est le dernier effet c'est qu'il en
restera toujours un syndrome post
traumatique
on parle de personnes qui sont
traumatisés qu'ils ont vécu quelque
chose de traumatisant donc il ya le
syndrome post traumatique qui sont à
régler une fois que la personne n'est
plus sous l'emprise du pervers
narcissique et là je m'arrête une
seconde là dessus est-ce qu'il faut
aider un pervers narcissique c'est à
dire imaginez vous êtes avertis par
cette vidéo vous n'êtes pas encore sûr
non prise de quelqu'un mais vous rendez
bien compte de tout ce qu'on est en
train de dire là c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer dans votre vie est ce
que il faut et est-ce qu'on peut aider
un pervers narcissique parfois on a
envie d'aider aussi parce que les
pervers narcissique sont immatures
émotionnellement parlant et c'est ça qui
donne envie déjà de les protéger
c'est dans le propre de l'être humain et
des personnes altruistes quant à
quelqu'un qui est mature ça te fait
penser un peu à un enfant ou un
adolescent donc qui ont envie de prendre
soin de la personne alors le meilleur
moyen de les aider c'est de poser des
limites mais poser des limites ça veut
dire quitter le pervers narcissique
si c'est un couple ça veut dire rompre
si ça en amitié ça veut dire c'est ça 6
et professionnellement couper les ponts
fan de toutes les manières le mot
quitter dans le sens il faut couper les
ponts mais à 100% avec cette personne
c'est le meilleur moyen d aider mais
parce que en réalité il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas d aider ou pas les aider c'est pas
le problème le problème ça reste
toujours la victime ou les victimes
avant de se poser la question comment on
peut aider le père 6-6 et comment on
ramasse les dégâts qui ont été faits sur
les victimes et comme on fera en sorte
que cette personne n'en fasse plus le
pervers narcissique ne demande pas dead
il n'a pas besoin d'elle puisque de
toute manière la faute c'est les autres
donc seule question à se poser c'est
comment je peux fuir cette relation
toxique la seule chose qui va les
impacts est vraiment qui va les faire
réagir pour de vrai c'est quand vous
expliquer un pervers narcissique qu'il
fait mal c'est-à-dire qu'il se comporte
mal ou que ce qu'il a fait c'est pas
bien et ça quand vous le critiquez quand
vous remettez en question une action
qu'il a pu faire par exemple leur vie
des migrants auprès de quelqu'un alors 6
et professionnellement par exemple il
s'attache à aller vous dénigrez à
l'endroit où vous voulez postuler par
exemple ce genre de chose si c'est en
relation affective eh bien il va aller
vous dénigrez auprès de votre ami ni
auprès des personnes que vous pourriez
rencontrer ça ça va énerver au sens fort
violent le pervers narcissique il ya ce
genre de choses ça le l'obligerait en
fait à ceux mettant dissonance cognitive
donc c'est pas possible ça va le faire
des compensées de la même manière les
pleurs de la victime vont l'énerver
alors que c'est lui détruit c'est lui
qui jouit de cette souffrance messier la
personne pleurs pleurniche
tout en étant même d'accord avec lui eh
bien ça ça peut le mettre ça peut le
mettre en colère alors les solutions ne
sont pas nombreuses on peut essayer de
se protéger d'un pervers narcissique
mais ce n'est pas une solution qui
durent longtemps parce que d'une manière
ou d'une autre il va finir toujours par
irradié vous serez infectés entre
guillemets par sa présence et par ces
manipulations psychologiques
c'est un petit peu comme si tu demander
à quelqu'un de lire que ces commentaires
négatifs sur youtube en lui demandant de
rien ressentir à un moment donné les
commentaires négatifs ils vont
s'immiscer dans la pensée ils vont
s'immiscer dans le moral est donc ça
aura un impact donc on peut pas se
protéger en tout cas mon temps la vraie
solution on l'a dit c'est fuir partir de
s'éloigner ce bar est évidemment osé en
parler oser demander de l'aide à son
entourage même des personnes avec qui on
s'est fâché à cause de cette personne là
eh bien il faut vite renouer reprendre
contact et dire écoute je crois qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va pas est ce qu'on
pourrait se parler se voir et c'est en
discuter il il faut absolument recréer
les contacts pour se faire aider à fuir
c'est jamais simple d'arrêter une
relation amicale professionnels
amoureuse surtout quand on est sous
l'emprise de quelqu'un d'autre donc il
faut pas hésiter certainement pas bien
au contraire à en parler pour se faire
aider et accompagner et commencer à
entrevoir les choses différemment le
pervers narcissique tous qu'il va
reprocher à une personne c'est ce qui se
reproche à lui-même il en a pas
conscience et gardez vous bien de lui
dire parce que c'est pas son projet
d'entendre ça mais s'il dit s'il dit
t'as vu tu payes jamais le resto en plus
c'est moi qu'il le fait tu es vraiment
épingle une pince c'est que la personne
elle-même et radis en fait c'est lui qui
a un problème avec l'argent s'il dit
qu'en permanence qui ne fait que de
mentir c'est parce que 1000 ne fait que
de mentir c'est qu'il est là son
problème s'il dit tu es de mauvaise foi
c'est parce qu'il est de mauvaise foi
donc il va reprocher à l'autre qui est
déjà ancrée en lui parce que c'est ce
qu'il sait reconnaître on va terminer
avec qu'est ce qui va se passer le jour
où vous allez arrêter une relation avec
un pervers narcissique action quelque
ordre qu'elle soit c'est certainement la
partie la plus intéressante de la vidéo
parce que peut-être qu'en la regardant
ça vous a fait penser quelque chose que
vous vivez vous même et donc le conseil
vous sera utile où ça va vous donner une
vision de personnes que vous connaissez
qui se sont faits en fait complètement
manipulé détruire par des personnes
comme ça très brillante en fait qui
cache une toxicité de pervers
narcissique et ces personnes-là bon
vivre des choses pas faciles et c'est
important vous les connaissiez pour
pouvoir les aider surtout pour ne jamais
remettre en question ce que ces
personnes disent à partir de ce moment
là parce que malheureusement le pervers
narcissique n'a pas fini l'aventuré au
moment où la personne coupe la relation
ça va se passer en quatre points la
première chose qui va faire c'est que le
pervers narcissique va disqualifier sa
victime pour nuire à son image le plus
possible et donc ce qu'il faisait sur
elle il va le faire puissances disent
publiquement socialement auprès de
toutes les personnes susceptibles de la
connaître il va essayer de d'empoisonner
complètement cuit il va essayer de lui
nuire dans un seul but préserver sa
propre image poterie garante où tout le
monde aime et qui nourrit son
narcissisme initial la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il va prendre à partie tout
l'entourage de cette personne pour se
faire passer pour la victime si ces
professionnels il va prendre tous les
collègues les amis et la famille si
c'est une relation amoureuse tous les
amis de ce couple donc il va se faire
passer pour la victime il va se plaindre
il va expliquer tout ce que vous lui
avait fait subir tout ce que la victime
lui a fait subir et en plus de ça il va
la traiter de fous où de folles et
peut-être même deux pervers narcissique
il va renverser complètement la vapeur
la troisième chose il peut la faire en
plus ou la faire si justement il
n'arrive pas à bien faire les deux
premières étapes il va chercher à briser
complètement sa victime ou son ancienne
victime alors là tous les coups sont
permis ça peut être de l'humiliation
publique qui ça fait du sabotage il va
mettre toute son énergie en tout cas
toutes ces stratégies pour briser
complètement la victime la dernière
étape qui peut franchir c'est tenté de
s'excuser alors dites vous bien que le
pervers narcissique n'éprouve aucun
remords et coquine de ces excuses ne
seront sincères il peut le faire dans
plusieurs situations parce que déjà il
ya un manque de sa victime parce qu'il
l'a peut-être plus de références
narcissique pour le nourrir lui-même
donc il va appeler qui va essayer de
réenclencher la machine qu'est une autre
manière de détruire donc il va dire
peut-être qu'il est désolé il va essayer
de faire réagir en fait l'autre aux
personnes toujours en huit lots en
maîtrisant les personnes qui ont accès à
cette information en disant qu'ils
s'excusent qu'il est rien sans cette
personne que cette personne là les
formidables que lui il est complètement
nul qu'il est lamentable etc etc donc il
va de nouveau se victimiser mais sans
incriminer ce coup ci la victime pour
que la victime est de nouveau envie de
le protéger envie de l'aider et qu'elle
reparte dans le processus initial voilà
j'ai essayé de vous faire une vidéo
assez complète sur le sujet et sans
qu'elle soit trop lourd j'espère que
c'était pas trop le cas mais en même
temps je crois que j'étais très
important d'en parler au moins une fois
en profondeur comme ça sur la chaîne
pour toutes les raisons que je vous ai
cités
vous pensez être victime d'un pervers
narcissique parlez-en à vos amis à votre
famille etc parlez-en à des contacts
dont vous vous seriez fâché à cause de
cette personne-là aller vérifier les
choses aussi par vous-même et recréer du
lien social rapidement et puis si vous
avez connaissance d'une personne qui a
était factuellement victime d'un pervers
narcissique n'oubliez pas que le pervers
où la paire vers va tout faire pour
c'est à dire sa personne pour la
détruire pour la démentir donc soyons
toujours plus à l'écouté de la victime
que du bureau prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao